una carrera de tanques unos ejercicios
militares en momentos de tensión del
ministerio de defensa ruso distribuidor
este jueves estas imágenes de su
poderoso ejército mientras el presidente
vladimir putin hacía una fuerte
advertencia dice putin que no descarta
intervenir en belarús si se lo pide su
aliado el presidente alexander
lukashenko en el cargo desde 1994 ese
país está marcado por la inestabilidad
desde las elecciones del 9 de agosto en
las que lukashenko se proclamó vencedor
primero hay que prender ayer
alexander me pidió crear una fuerza
policial de reserva para él así que lo
hice también acordamos que esa reserva
no sería usada a menos que la situación
se salga de control que es por poco es
un espaldarazo para lukashenko a quien
la oposición acusa de haber manipulado
los comicios del 9 de agosto él se
mantiene en la retórica de rechazar el
diálogo con sus detractores
mientras tanto en las calles de minsk
las protestas se hacen casi habituales
este jueves unos 20 periodistas fueron
retenidos temporalmente mientras
intentaba cubrir esta amanera
se estima que desde elecciones tres
personas han muerto y decenas han
resultado heridas como consecuencia de
las intervenciones policiales todo el
pueblo de belarús ha sido oprimido en
los últimos 26 años y especialmente
durante los últimos tres meses desde la
unión europea insisten en pedirle
diálogo a lukashenko el organismo
comunitario ha solicitado además tener
acceso a las cárceles en donde se
encuentran los detenidos en las
protestas una cifra que sería de más de
siete mil personas